(gun shots)
- So we're here today
at Oak Tree Gun Club,
and we're gonna shoot a bunch of stuff
that you see utilized in movies,
or that you just have around your house,
to see what's actually bulletproof.
Disclaimer: we're here with professionals
in a safe environment.
Do not try this at home.
We're testing it for you.
(rock music)
- Today, we are going to be using the
.22 long rifle round,
which is a lighter bullet
that travels very fast.
We're gonna be using a
nine millimeter Luger,
and we are going to be using a
.460 Smith and Wesson Magnum.
- [Woman] What does the most damage?
- [Robert] The .460, hands down.
- 'Cause it's the biggest?
- It's the longest casing with
the most powder behind it.
It's also the heaviest bullet, so you get
a lot of weight with a
lot of velocity behind it.
95% of the stuff you
see in movies, it's...
No.
- [Woman] It doesn't work?
- It doesn't work.
- They're a bunch of liars.
- For the most part.
- The ol' frying pan flip trick.
- We're gonna try and
shoot a cast iron skillet
with a nine millimeter and
a .460 Smith and Wesson.
- [Robert] I think the
.460's gonna go through it.
- Kate's gonna go home without a skillet.
(laughter)
Sorry!
(gun firing)
Oh! That went through!
- Nope.
- What do you mean "No?"
- Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah it did.
(gun firing)
- Two holes. We've got two holes.
Nine millimeter hit it,
almost in a bull's eye.
- I actually thought the
nine would bounce off of it.
- It went right through.
Turns out, cast iron
skillet: not a great shield.
Noted.
It's time to shoot an iPhone.
We're gonna shoot it with
a nine millimeter gun.
We've only got one shot.
(gun firing)
The iPhone didn't survive.
(laughter)
The front doesn't look so bad.
The back looks pretty terrible.
We're gonna shoot a car door.
My prediction is that
it will stop the .22.
(gun firing)
It looks like it went through.
- Jesus Christ!
- So this is the .22 hole,
that's the nine hole,
and this is the .460?
- The nine went through for sure.
- The .22 also went through!
That's crazy; all three of
them went through the door.
Get out of your car!
(laughter)
- You guys wanna shoot the table?
- [Man In Sweater] Yeah we do!
(cheering)
- So we're gonna shoot a table,
because I feel like, in every movie,
you always see people
hiding behind tables.
And this time, we get to shoot the gun.
- Go ahead and pick those up,
keep your fingers off the trigger.
Go ahead and watch your barrels,
you're gonna take aim at that table.
Everybody's got eyes and ears on?
One, two, three.
(guns firing)
There we go.
- Oh yeah, right through the top there.
- That was Gustav.
After all we've seen today,
the chair's probably
not gonna stop a bullet,
so we might as well just
put a bunch of them in it.
Right?
- [Voiceover] Yep!
- Yeah!
(guns firing)
We just blew up the chair!
So guns work.
What we learned today was
that guns do their jobs,
and movies are fake,
but I feel like we
probably knew that already.
- But you don't need to squeeze the gun.
I'm talking to you.
- What?
I've got a very soft touch.
- Uh huh.
Tell that to that Rav 4.
(laughing)
You probably ripped it
right off the car, right?